six one seven eight three zero 47 50
let's go to our caller from the 202 area
code caller from - OH - go ahead
my name is I'm from DC definitely okay
are we on speaker [ __ ] DC no I'm I
don't think okay good all right I just
having trouble hearing you go ahead okay
imma try again um oh that's much better
oh I'm from DC okay great I'm from DC
and basically it's almost expensive here
in New York no one can afford to live it
the only thing that we can honestly
think of doing is moving to a more rural
area right and I'm trying to figure out
how long is it gonna take for America to
come back after Trump okay so hold on a
second are you saying that DC is that
expensive because of Trump it is that
expensive but I mean if my name was on
it DC my question was are you saying
that DC has gotten this expensive
because of Trump I won't say it because
of Trump okay I mean I think that's a
little grant but I'm just saying you see
you've gotten so expensive right and
it's you know we're going to do
gentrification and all the people that
were here before with being pushed out
yeah you're simply unaffordable and I'm
just saying I I mean I know my question
is silly and probably really you know
scale down - no no I mean listen it's a
good problem because this is going on in
New York City this is happening in
Boston this is happening in LA San
Francisco Washington DC it has nothing
to do with Trump right this is way
bigger than Trump has been going on for
a long time right I don't know the
answer I've been reading a lot about
this problem and there's one view which
is we need way more housing stock like
just way more places to live need to be
built if you've got more supply then
it's gonna decrease the demand that
allows these outrageous prices to be
charged you know five six thousand
dollars for a one-bedroom apartment in
San Francisco right crazy crazy price
right the other that's what a market
that's like a market solution the other
side of it is more regulatory which is
there need to be more subsidies for
housing but all of these solute
so-called solutions have problems and I
don't I have not yet read any good
analysis of what it will take to fix
this problem and it's a major major
problem I wish I had better news
Noah but thank you thank you for your
for your for your info we will we
appreciate it
all right thank you really appreciate it
thank you appreciate it great to hear
from DC a really important issue I wish
I wish I had a more optimistic point of
view